the gameplay premiere for hyrule
warriors age of calamity happened at
tokyo game show 2020. along with a new
trailer and some info from the
developers we've picked out a few
details that you might have missed
here are 8 things we learned from hyrule
warriors age of calamity tokyo game
shows showcase
breath of the wild is the sole focus of
this game the original hyrule warriors
was a celebration of all things zelda
with characters and locations from
multiple games in the series
in this game however its sole focus is
the world and characters of breath of
the wild
so don't count zelda characters from the
entire timeline to show up
age of calamity takes place 100 years
before the events of birth of the wild
in the period shown through the memories
unlocked in the game
so this time koei tecmo worked more
closely with the zelda development team
on gameplay
characters and the depiction of hyrule
if you played the original hyrule
warriors you'll feel right at home
with age of calamity you'll gain a
special attack after defeating a certain
amount of enemies
have the ability to switch characters
mid battle use attack to combo skill
trees and acquire crafting materials for
upgrades
all things that will feel familiar if
you played the first hyrule warriors
after watching this recent gameplay we
suggest that if you want to get a leg up
in age of calamity
playing the original hyrule warriors is
a good way to get some practice in
beforehand
some interesting combat things link will
have access to the shortcut menu by
holding
r then pressing x y a or b which gives
them chica slate abilities courtesy of
our new little guardian friend
the interesting part is that in the
newly released trailer daruk is also
seen using stasis as well
meaning that this companion may possibly
be passed around to different champions
to let them all use sheikah slate
abilities
impa is also seen here using a seal
system numbered in the corner in chica
writing as letters
f s and t most likely first second and
third seals
letting her access another layer of
clones on each side of her and giving
her larger attacks
we got to see more of the little
guardian but it's still a mystery
first seen on the promotional art for
age of calamity the little guardian is
largely still a mystery
but we did get to see it up close it
looks like the sheikah slate awakened it
causing it to make the shika tower
appear
and it follows link around during combat
it's also seen following the main
characters around during cutscenes
what's its purpose we don't know is it
cute
heck yeah it is impa might not be the
only
new playable shika character impo was
revealed to be a new playable character
in age of calamity this makes sense that
she was one of the characters she
encountered in breath of the wild who
was alive during the attack 100 years
prior
but according to a rough translation
impa reportedly mentions pura pura is
impu's older sister who experimented
with an anti-aging rune
and became the young looking woman that
we see in breath of the wild is pura
going to be a playable character too
it's not entirely out of the realm of
possibility for a warriors game
other minor characters are also
confirmed to make an appearance while
it's unclear if any of these characters
are playable
we did see some minor characters from
breath of the wild make an appearance in
the new age of calamity trailer
this includes young sidon who was first
introduced in the champions ballot dlc
for breath of the wild
king dorfian who is mifa and sidon's
father and the great deku tree
fighting as a great deku tree sounds
like a lot of fun but it's probably too
overpowered
the game will be dubbed in english
during the stream nintendo released a
new trailer on their english channels
which revealed that the game will be
dubbed
at least the cutscenes will there was
some dialogue heard in the original
trailer but it was the same reused voice
lines from breath of the wild
it's unclear at this time whether
everyone in the original cast is
returning
but this is a welcome change from the
original hyrule warriors which just had
grunts during cut scenes as text was
appearing
only japan is getting the cool edition
during the panel we got a closer look at
the treasure box edition of age of
calamity which includes goodies like an
acrylic art plate a metal guardian charm
and a blanket design like link's
parasail unfortunately this edition was
said to be only coming to japan
and will not come overseas thankfully
the nintendo switch is region free so
feel free to try and order anyways
although quantities are limited and some
retailers already went live
and that's it age of calamity is less
than two months away at this point so
it's not much longer before we get our
hands on it wouldn't it be nice to not
have it come out on the day after
cyberpunk 2077
sure but we can't always get what we
want if you're looking for the full
gameplay sequence from the stream or the
entire stream itself
head over to our youtube channel and for
more age of calamity coverage and
everything zelda stay tuned to gamespot
you